is the iPhone 14 pro way over processed
well today I have two professional
photographers with me to find out hi I'm
Eugene I've shot over 600 weddings and
thousands of real estate homes and I'm
van I am also a real estate photographer
I've shot thousands of homes as well
over 2 000 by this point and I do a lot
of editing so we'll see how this Stacks
up yeah you guys know that we enjoy our
Apple products and we do these unbiased
tests when I go out when I take a ton of
different photos and a bunch of
different lighting scenarios we have the
pixel 7 Pro and the s22 ultra with the
latest updates so go ahead and grab a
piece of paper and a pen vote with us
which one you like best and let's find
out if the iPhone is over processed now
here we have our first image we have
Alina and Elon what do you guys think I
like the center one the best when I look
at the one on the right it's a little
bit too cool for me the dynamic range
isn't as good the one on the left is too
warm and there's too much Color cast
that I see for me the right one again is
also too cool uh too much blue going on
uh the left one seemed like it has a
gradient going from top to bottom and I
think the middle one is just right so
that one was the the one I choose all
right let's see what that one is and
that is the pixel so Google did a good
job there good job Google and here is
our next image this has artificial LED
lighting inside what do you guys think
so for this one um on the left I think
the face is a bit too dark I think the
background is messing with that it's
making everything uh it's having a hard
time with white balance uh the middle
one is a bit too warm uh for me so I
think I will I I like the right one the
most this one's honestly hard for me to
decide I like how the center one is more
lit up the subject the face is more lit
up but it's a little bit too warm for me
so I will actually go with the right one
as well so both of you guys with the
right one yes yeah the iPhone so so it's
interesting that you do have gradients
on the face and it is darker whereas
people have talked about the iPhone's
faces being way too bright so here we
have a real estate shot for you guys and
there's a lot of differences there it's
a tough situation we have snow what do
you guys think the most natural looking
one for me is the one on the right uh
even though it seemed a little cool I
think the middle one's a bit too warm uh
last one is I see too much I see kind of
some purple fringing going out I like
the right one as well I think it looks
natural the colors look a lot more
accurate even though it's cooler I can
tell that it's shot in the winter the
center one I can see green in there and
it's a White House yeah it's a white
house so uh just the coloring is
probably not to my taste and the left
one uh there's not enough detail it's
blown out I can see a lot more detail in
the paneling on the left one so I'm
gonna choose the right
the pixel once again so far no votes for
Samsung all right so here we have a shot
of Vadim now in this lighting scenario
we want shadowing on the face which one
do you like the best for me the most
natural looking one is the left one the
middle one that has a bit too much
Shadow processing the right one is too
warm for me so for me um I'm gonna
actually differ with Eugene I like the
center one I like that the skin looks
more natural at least to me I like the
colors but yeah it is a little bit more
flat because the shadowing there there's
not as much contrast in the shadows so
the the face is brought up too much yes
but I do like how natural the colors
look on the center and we have iPhone
and pixel for that one I'll just say
it's interesting how the pixel's face is
brought up more so than the iPhone at
least in this scenario now this is a
similar shot but it is a video to see
how the video processing goes so would
you guys change your mind what you would
vote on uh for me no I could still sell
this one's a bit too cool this one's a
bit warm and the right one is
just right for me I actually prefer the
left I noticed that uh it's weird but I
notice a lot more shaking on the center
one so uh I like the stabilization on
the left and I do like the colors it's a
little bit cooler
um but it just looks natural to me all
right so we have iPhone and pixel did
you guys vote the same as last time I
did yeah so the processing and video is
matching up no love for the Samsung so
here we have a portrait mode shot what
do you guys think I gotta say none of
these look like a real camera none of
them it's super it's super harsh
lighting this is a really tough uh shot
that you know for any photographer I
would have a hard time delivering any
one of these images dang I did have to
have Alina like close your eyes and it's
a count to have her open shot so this
has a ton of processing from the phone
so which one looks the closest or which
one do you like the best I prefer the
left one
um even though I really like the bokeh
on the right one
um but it's so it just seems a bit too
warm so for me I actually prefer to
Center I don't like how bokeh it looks
it looks a little too fake for me but I
do like that the subject looks really
good
in the center like properly lit up
another thing I want to point out is you
could see in the uh in the elbow part of
the image uh that didn't cut it out just
apply bokeh to that part of the image so
it missed it yep so we have the left and
the right and that is the iPhone and the
pixel Ben have you been picking the
pixel so far yes I think with a lot of
the other ones I got one iPhone 5 pixel
so far wow okay we'll see now here we
have a tough landscape kind of shot this
is all with the regular lenses so we
have 48 megapixel 50 and 108 which one
do you like best I prefer the one I
prefer the one on the left the right one
again has I see purple for engine and a
bit a bit too much over processing uh
for me I actually like the center one
here
um it looks more natural to me the one
on the left looks a little bit too warm
um but I I do agree with Eugene I do see
some of the fringing as well so Center
for me so leptin Center we have iPhone
and pixel again the Samsung 100
megapixels we're opposite
me and Eugene are officer here so here
we have Elon in the snow with a bright
Sky what do you think ah this is a hard
one it is uh the middle one does seem
like it's lacking some contrast uh
between the right and the left again I
see purple fringing um I could almost
tell is the same camera each time so you
have good eyes
let me try to predict the future here so
the right one is the Samsung the middle
is the pixel and the left is the iPhone
I'm having a very hard time choosing
this this one looks more natural to me
I like how the subjects you can see the
subject better it's better lit on the
um yeah better processed in my opinion
so I'm actually gonna go for this I'm
gonna go with the left one but I think
the right one looks more natural left on
both for left is this the first time you
guys are agreeing first time we agree
wow I'm glad I have both of you guys on
and you guys both chose the pixel I was
wrong on this one so I'm glad we saw
some mystery going on here by the way
both of us are iPhone fans so this is uh
are you interested in an iPhone yeah
I think most photographers have iPhones
at least that I've met alright so here
is another shot now this one is taken
with their telephoto lenses we have
harsh lighting what do you guys think
for this one I I think the middle one
looks the best um I don't know if it's
just doing more smoothing than the right
ones you can tell the left and the
middle are kind of doing more smoothing
over the face yeah the right one is just
it's a bit too sharp uh so my gut says
middle one as well I like the middle one
I feel like this one's on the on the
left a little bit too bright but the
processing looks pretty good so left one
too bright right one too sharp the
middle is the pixel the pixel is doing
quite well here nothing for Samsung come
on Samsung we'll see what happens with
the night mode here we have a zoom Shot
One camera has a 10x one has a 5x one
only has a 3X but they're all zoomed
digitally to the same so which one looks
best uh the right one again a bit too
much sharpening too cool I think the
middle one is just right uh the left one
looks a little bit blurry to me um I
gotta say the exact same thing exact
same thing that makes it easy and the
pixel looks better which is weird the
Samsung has a 10x Optical instead of 5x
but it looks way over sharpened and over
processed and here we have very harsh
lighting with a selfie for me gut
instinct Center I like the colors I like
that the Shadows are not too harsh I
understand it's not the most natural but
I feel like it does a good job blending
that's the one you'd want yeah
yeah that would be the one uh for me
that centered the skin tones are a
little bit blown out the high on the
Highlight section uh I'm gonna go with
the left on this one so we have the
first Samsung
and an iPhone and this is a video clip
there's a lot of different lighting HDR
you guys take a look but I'll start
right here on the left one you can see
the highlights are really blowing out on
the right side of your face the middle
one is doing a great job of keeping it
more neutral excited I like the center
one the most
um I think the the blending is really
well the you know picks up the Shadows
real well the stabilization is really
good on the center one you don't think
it's over processed I don't think it's
over processed there is a little bit too
much flaring uh when there is a flare
but that's the only downside but overall
I would choose the center all right
let's see what that is both of you guys
for Center oh and that is the Samsung
people say iPhone has the best video it
definitely has good video yeah but in
this case the Samsung wins wow yeah all
right we have a truck shot here my truck
is black what do you think looks the
best I see a green fringing on the
driver door and purple fringing more on
the left one I'm gonna go with the right
so I'm gonna go with the right as well
it looks the most natural to me
um that's the one I like
that is the the pixel I'm so glad we
have professional photographers here you
guys are doing a great job here we have
a tough shot we have snow bright Sky I
think the the left one is my favorites
here
um it doesn't have any color for engine
uh does a good job of being neutral for
me the last left one as well I also
noticed a little bit more detail in the
light fixture right there so I like that
and the colors are good too another one
for the pixel very good job Google when
we first when this phone first came out
we did a comparison and I feel like the
software was not up to par yet but right
before we do this test we updated all of
the phones and I think it's really
stepped up its game so here we have
another harsh lighting situation from
from the side uh which is not how I'd
normally take it but I wanted to see
those harsh Shadows so what do you guys
think I think too much uh Shadows on the
left
um not enough shadows in the middle and
I think the right one has just the right
amount I'm gonna go with the right
this one's hard for me I actually I'm
gonna choose the left one I like the
saturation it's a little bit too much
saturation but if she was in the sun you
know the lights usually bring out color
um in my opinion and I like I like that
it's more saturated on the left so we
have it right and a left Nola for the
middle and we have a Samsung and a pixel
and the iPhone you can tell that the
face is brought up too much all right
here we have an interior real estate
type shot if you were sending this to a
client you have to choose one which one
would you choose uh the right one is
definitely a known though so the
maintaining about real estate photos is
uh not blown out windows which we have
on the right the middle one halfway
there right and I think the left is just
right it has
um you know good good good Windows while
keeping the inside somewhat right
sometimes I do I'm okay with a little
bit Windows blown out for Real Estate I
really like the colors the colors look
more natural on the right one however
the left one I it's Blended way better
and so like if I have to do a compromise
if I had to send something it would be
the left one but I would color correct
it a little bit more the pixel so the
iPhone looks more natural than the
Samsung but it has more blown out
windows yeah and this is a portrait shot
so we have the blur effect and it's
backlit with the Sun as well with some
flaring middle one looks like it has a
Instagram filter applied over it there's
no extra filters brown brown tones going
on there so a bit too much process I
think on that one I'm gonna go with it
right here so I'm actually going to
choose the same thing I think left is
too bright uh the center one's too dark
and I think the exposure on the right
one is really good and you guys both
chose the iPhone for this one so the
pixel yeah it's quite dark in there and
here we have a selfie in the shadows
with a bright Sky I think the right one
has a bit too much Shadows it's not
doing a good job of brightening the face
especially on your sun there uh the left
one it looks like it has uh Sun flares
in the labs like it's they were actually
no it looks like it but it wasn't
actually any sun in there so I think
it's doing some over processing on the
shadow side I think I like the warm the
Warmness of the middle and know good
Shadows good contrast I'm gonna go over
the middle it's really hard for me so I
do not like the right one uh same I
think it's the right one's the worst
right one's the worst has too much
contrast too much darks if I may add I
feel like there's always like bringing
out skin issues like out of my face that
you don't really notice like yeah maybe
over sharpening it's almost doing like a
Clarity slider in like the clarity just
brings out all those for Real Estate it
looks good but if you do it on the
person's face it looks horrible yeah so
that's the muscle of a process yeah
look at you Lightroom guys so
um the left looks a little bit too cool
and not enough contrast the center one I
love the contrast it's a little too warm
but if I had to choose it'd be the
center one from my opinion YouTuber
opinion I love the suno and I feel like
it looks so detailed but not over sharp
and like no
no both of you guys chose the Samsung
and it actually has a 40 megapixel front
camera instead of like 12. so I I think
it's noticeable in the detail like a
notice in the hair right here
um it's sharper so this is a white
building and with the Sun hitting us and
the building so what do you think too
much green on the right again too much
too much purple on the left and I
attempted tomato is just right that's
for me for me the colors are not the big
the big design factor here I like the
center one the exposure I feel like it's
well exposed the highlights are really
well exposed all right and that is the
pixel so the iPhone has too much green
which we've talked about before so here
we have some delicious coffee uh a
waffle Sun hitting it with shadows what
do you think which one would you want to
eat and drink choose well uh I feel like
the left one's over saturated for me I
really like the center
um so I'm going to choose the center one
it just looks the one the most like well
balanced uh this is a window shot so I
think it has natural contrast so I
actually prefer more contrast on this
one so I'm gonna go with a lot all right
no love for the right and we have
Samsung and pixel the iPhone does not
get chosen now this is the same window
right there a lot of bright sun with
clouds and shadows inside what do you
guys think so for me the left one looks
the most natural with the perfect
contrast but if I look closer on the top
right there are some extreme noise uh
filtering going on so you could really
see those that color Fringe in there
um so I actually have second thoughts
about that one uh the right one actually
does not have any noise on the top right
the middle still does so I'm gonna go
with the right on this one yeah I agree
with Eugene
um the noise is too much on the left one
but I got say if you don't look for it
right if you don't look for it you can't
really
um if you're just looking at the person
if you're not looking at this weird post
you just crop in more yeah yeah so my
actually gut I don't know why
um but it was actually at the center and
I think I'm gonna still keep it at the
center I just like it the most so we
have Center and right we have the s22
and the iPhone now we get into some
darker cooler outdoor lighting when the
clouds came in so I like the left I like
the exposure I like the colors on the
left uh the other ones look a little bit
too cool for me I agree with Van here
I'm gonna go with the left here same
reasons we got another pixel shot we
need to switch over to pixel yeah most
professional photographers use iPhone
but I don't know if they should you have
any pixel discount code
[Laughter]
so here we have uh another shot this is
portrait with the long lens I prefer the
left here even though it's not very
color accurate I prefer to be more
warmer uh but the face is sharp it's it
looks like it's doing some selective
face brightening it does a really good
job on that so I'm gonna go with it so
it's brightening the face but not too
much but not too much just right yes now
do you brighten faces and for photos yep
so even professional photographers
brighten face is not only smartphones
van which one do you like best I feel
like now I'm biased because Eugene
commented and I can see
I think initially my reaction was the
right one yeah it's just a little too
cool for me on the left so I'm gonna
choose the right one the right one yeah
okay we have the Samsung and the iPhone
come on iPhone I'm roon free here's a
portrait shop but we're using the wide
camera that's way too much sharpening
going on on the left uh the individual
hairs on the face way overdone the right
one same thing I think the white balance
is off even though they're using less
sharpening
the middle one looks a bit too warm but
I'm gonna go with it uh I think it has
just the right amount of sharpening huh
and this one I actually I think I prefer
the right one
um for me that one looks a little more
color accurate I agree with Eugene the
center one is a little too warm but I
like to see a little bit more of the
detail in the brick so the bulk is not
overdone for me on the on the right one
all right we have Samsung and iPhone for
that one and we have another video here
really tough lighting let's take a look
so I'm gonna guess the left one is a
Samsung but and that's the one I like
the best I remember from the last video
it looked kind of similar I like the
exposure the exposure is really nice on
this one exactly the same for me I think
the right and the middle is a bit too
dark especially the right one is it's
almost like a whole stop darker than the
other ones but I agree I like the left
one the most that was actually the
iPhone I'm surprised they dropped so it
got the white balance pretty much spot
on where some of the photos there looked
too cool which is interesting here we
have a shot of some Flames so definitely
more details on the left and the right
in the actual Flames the middle one is
blowing it out it looks like for the uh
it wants to bring the background
brighter I don't know if it's just an
Explorer thing but but I took like three
or four shots with each phone to make
sure it's not just a fluke this is
actually how it takes it each time what
I I like the one on the left there's
more detail I think it's because the
shutter was working faster
um and it was able to capture it better
it's more sharp because of that I'm
going to choose the last one yeah I'm
going with the left as well perfect same
read both pixel and I was surprised how
well it did and it really it's almost
like it knew that it's fired there and
to focus on yeah yeah compared to the
Samsung recognition it might be scene
recognition yeah okay so we have this
shot where it's really cool lighting a
lot of color so I like the left one
um it just I like that it's a little
brighter
um I like the contrast I like the
sharpness I agree with when here left
ones most perfect you say it's the most
natural too yes the right one is a bit a
bit blurry but it has purple color cast
the middle one's a bit kind of no man's
land on the white balance so left and
that is the iPhone it's interesting when
the lighting starts changing
um you know especially when it gets
really dark
stuff can flip so here we have a sign
neon but it's also dark I like the
center one yeah this the left one's too
blown out the right one's too dark for
me the center looks just right yes same
for me exactly the same reasons
another one for the iPhone I was
surprised that the pixel got the neon
pretty well uh I would say a year ago
most phones would do this until the
iPhone started doing that now the pixel
is doing that too now this got really
dark so to my eyes it was darker than
all of these so I'm gonna say the center
I think I see better so better better
colors in the center one but also more
detail in the center one in the faces
for this one for me that's another one
has a bit too much sharpening going on
especially with all the all the trees in
the background uh the left one has I
can't even tell her I don't think about
it you know everything but I do like the
right one the most the right one so we
have Center and right
no love for the iPhone here here's a
shot with a longer lens and I think this
was supposed to be a portrait shot but
maybe it was just too far away uh the
middle and the right are definitely more
blurrier
um the left one I think is just spot on
I'm gonna go with the left I'm gonna go
with the left as well I um it looks a
little bit over sharpened in this area
but I do like to see detail in the face
and I think that's the most important so
both left and I'll say like this looks
almost like daytime like it brought it
up so much yeah it warmed it up where
um that still looks like night
both of you guys for the pixel I think
you guys might have to trade in your
iPhones after this video here's a shot
uh Elon slipped and decided he wanted a
picture there so there's a lot of color
going on so I'm gonna choose the one on
the right the left one's too blurry and
I think the colors are the best on the
on the right I'm gonna go with the left
one here
um I think the blur in this is maybe
from camera shake or from your son
moving but I think the colors are more
natural not over saturated okay and you
chose the pixel then chose the Samsung
so one thing these all are all using
night mode when it's this dark the pixel
for this one takes about seven seconds
to take that picture believe it or not
the iPhone uh takes about two seconds
and the Samsung takes about five okay so
no wonder he's blurry so I took multiple
shots in each one uh was blurry like
that I mean try to spend still for seven
seconds you know
so here's a portrait shot with some
Christmas lights behind them so I'm
going to choose the one on the left it
just has a more Christmassy Vibe that's
what I'm gonna choose that is true yes I
think I like the left one too it's a bit
warmer
um although I think it's the same so I'm
gonna because Samsung so far has been
giving it very warm images
you were right
another video clip I believe it's the
last one let's go and take a look
so the first thing I noticed is a bit
too much motion border on the left on
the middle I think the right one almost
has no motion blur it's like the left
and the middle is is like he's more
frames in between
um so I'm gonna go with the right
so I actually like the exposure of the
left one so I'm gonna go with the left
we have an iPhone and a pixel yeah the
Samsung one look I saw the most
stuttering almost like it is dropping
frames in order to make it brighter or
less noise or something so here's a
tough shot he was standing between two
of these Christmas trees a lot of lights
with Reflections and a lot of processing
because it's portrait too and for this
one I see the right one is also blurrier
and you mentioned that on the the Sams
the pixel takes seven seconds for a
photo this one might not be a pixel well
these are all telephoto as well so it's
using the a longer zoom lens that could
also affect things but which one do you
think looks the best I think the red one
like the best
we'll see yeah so I actually like the
right one as well
um the left one's a little bit too
blurry and then this it's too sharp for
the standard one for me yeah I agree on
that and I don't know if it messed up on
some of the blur or or uh it's supposed
to be a portrait yeah so for portion
mode right one for sure and that is the
iPhone oh for that one so the pixel is
the one that was sharper this time but
it messed it up all right here is we're
almost at the end here this is inside
the wagon the Red Wagon crazy dark I
couldn't even see her face I'm gonna go
with the one on the left I like the
colors
um the detail is good uh the center
one's a little bit too blown out and too
warm for me yeah I think the center one
is doing a bit too much processing you
can kind of see it on the uh on the rail
below the face there I'm gonna go with
the right on this one I think I think is
doing a great job so keeping it neutral
no love for the center one no
we have a pixel and a Samsung the iPhone
is just brought up way too much here's
the actual Red Wagon I like the right
one the most I think it has just the
right amount of contracts with no color
fringing or you know off-white balance
I'm gonna go with the right one as well
it looks more most natural to me yeah
and I think the red actually stands at
least to my eyes a little bit more
because it is a red wagon but at night
it actually looks like almost black
because of how dark it is that is the
Samsung another crazy dark shot here I
couldn't even see Elon so these phones
are amazing what they could do at night
I like the middle one here me too I like
the middle one that was easy
we have a pixel shot definitely a snap
blurry and it looks natural so that
looks good this one might be the last
one or one of the last we have a shot in
my car uh the telephoto lens I like the
left one I like that I feel like it's
better white balanced uh more natural
and I like the exposure as well I think
I like knew that it's a car and a neat
and that's the subject so kind of
brightened that up ah the left one's a
little too cool for me I like the right
one more so no love for the middle one
we have a pixel and an iPhone this is an
ultra wide shot very backlit with fog
which one would you want in your phone
neither
they all look terrible you need a flash
in this case yes so if I had to go with
it I like the fact that I can actually
see
um the face in the center one so I'm
gonna go with the center one um I'm
gonna go with the left on this one so no
right it's by far the darkest
and the iPhone did not get chosen now
one interesting thing is in this
scenario the iPhone didn't put a box
around the face where these two phones
did so it's interesting the iPhone and
when it doesn't see a face it makes the
whole thing way darker when it sees a
face it does try to bring that subject
up and a nighttime selfie it was
extremely dark crazy dark and I can't
believe that you can actually see me
there's a lot of grain on your uh on
your coat on the left image a lot nicer
you could really see it on all the dark
spots uh I'll go to your head too uh the
middle one looks like it has like video
fringing what is that called like
artifacting compression yes I think I
like the right one the most on this even
though it's the darkest I'm not trying
to change your opinion but yes I think I
mean if if you're in a dark scene I
would prefer to look natural that makes
sense yeah it matches up because they're
trying to overdo it so I like the right
one as well because I I don't think it's
over processed the other two look over
processed pixel one and the iPhone had a
ton of noise and that was the last image
so if you guys voted along with us go
ahead and comment down below let us know
which one you voted for the most and
what your votes were or what surprised
you and do you think that the iPhone is
over processed
um or do you think it does a decent job
and which phone is your favorite alright
guys so uh go ahead and comment below
you guys do you want to count yours up
all right they counted up their results
let's go ahead and find out which phone
won
so here's my results I have 12 for the
iPhone 14.
17 for the pixel Pro and 11 for the s22
so lab iPhone and Samsung were very
close one off but the pixel was
definitely in the lead yeah so for me I
got 10 for the iPhone 14 pro uh 23 for
Pixel 7 Pro and then seven for the
Samsung S2 Ultra so Samsung in worst
place by three not too far off though
from iPhone but the pixel by far
dominated I'm surprised you're surprised
I am did you expect that the iPhone
would do
yeah I'm so used to the iPhone making
such good photos yeah and I think for a
long time people thought that the iPhone
was the most natural a lot of Android
phones would have too much contrast too
much saturation but looks like Google's
done a great job of the processing their
scene recognition I know they have a
thing where depending on skin colors it
will adjust to make it more accurate
which they would working on the scene
recognition stuff like we saw so
definitely did a good job I think I came
into this with an iPhone bias and I
think I was proven wrong
that's good so this is why we do the
unbiased uh camera comparison so if you
guys enjoy these make sure you guys
click that subscribe button above you
can check out these phones using the
YouTube shopping feature down below
check out one of those great videos
right over there thank you guys for
coming and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]